the country is growing sexual misconduct
scandal is putting a new focus on a
controversial field sex addiction rehab
more than 80 women accused Harvey
Weinstein of sexual harassment or
assault and more than a dozen men
alleged sexual misconduct by Kevin
Spacey both men are now reportedly being
treated at the same upscale rehab
facility in Wickenburg Arizona but is
sex addiction a proven diagnosis or just
an excuse to retreat from the public eye
Jamie yuccas went to Phoenix to speak
with the founder of the program who
wouldn't confirm the identities of any
of his patients this is an interview
you'll see only on CBS this morning a
little more than an hour north of
Phoenix is the 35-acre sex addiction
treatment center gentle path at the
meadows the voluntary 45 day treatment
costs fifty eight thousand dollars
founder Patrick Carnes first popularized
the term sex addiction in the early
1980s like any other addiction it's a
problem where a person loses their
ability to choose it's a brain disease
Karn says and addicts behaviors can
range from watching porn excessively to
touching or exposing oneself in
inappropriate ways Harvey Weinstein and
Kevin Spacey join a list of celebrities
who've reportedly sought treatment for
sex addiction including Tiger Woods and
Anthony Weiner dr. Damon Raskin is with
the drug and alcohol treatment center
cliffside Malibu
he says sex addiction is not a
recognized disorder and therapy can be a
PR stunt if you call something an
addiction then it gives something to do
you know you have people like
celebrities that can then use that as a
disease model and go off to a rehab
center where they can spend a lot of
money and try to get the help that they
need dr. Raskin says brain scans of
people claiming sex addiction don't
match those addicted to drugs the
American Psychiatric Association does
not recognize sex addiction as a mental
illness there's no good evidence showing
that sex addiction is a true addiction
like drug and alcohol addiction there
are a number of doctors we've talked to
who say sex addiction isn't real
whenever there is a scientific
breakthrough there's controversy the
reality is the evidence for
the brain disease of addiction is
overwhelming treatment at gentle path
includes meditation journaling group
therapy and neurofeedback patients are
asked to commit to a celibacy contract
of at least eight weeks examining sexual
fantasies and creating a relapse
prevention plan so this isn't a vacation
not a vacation
it's like boot camp Karn says it can
take up to five years with extensive
therapy to reprogram an addicts brain
still his facility doesn't release data
on how many patients make a full
recovery
but as the list of those accused of
sexual misconduct continues to grow
Karns hopes the headlines will help
create change I think this will be one
of the most significant periods in our
history the good news in this is this
conversation for CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas Phoenix and we reached out
to both Spacey and Weinstein for comment
we have not heard back from Spacey and a
spokesman for Weinstein told us they
won't comment about reports of his
treatment